robert pattinson has been chaotic and  iconic from the start my friends yeah  they don't really care this is the night  here in harry potter if you had a sister  would you want her to date edward or  jacob well edward's wealthier  male music is always a kind of joke to  me you get on with the director and know  that they're not going to like do a  close-up of your ass crack or something  i guess at the beginning  what does happen in the beginning  fell in love with the baby what can you  do  yolo i kind of think most actors  look for these parts yeah maybe because  they're a little bit mentally unstable  in the first place are you  yeah it's kind of fun if you're just  like  so rob this is just the same we were  just sitting having dinner yeah but i  want to do it now i'm addicted to it